we turn to Nashville Tennessee where six
innocent people including three
nine-year-old little kids were murdered
by a Christian element at a Christian
Elementary School by an evil 28 year old
transgender person with a Manifesto and
a lot of plans made before the attack by
the way our prayers are with all the
victims all their families everyone at
the Covenant School tonight we're also
grateful for the very quick the heroic
response from the Nashville metropolitan
police department they eliminated this
shooter in less than 15 minutes after
receiving the 9-1-1 call these guys were
Heroes
let's go I need three more
one more
let's go
Metro Police let's go
now without this amazing response from
law enforcement you know what tonight we
don't know the exact motives but these
guys save the day and literally this
could have been far worse but yet
families lost loved ones and that's
never good according to reports we do
know that the shooter was planning to
attack another location but quote gave
up on the idea after doing a threat
assessment because the site had quote
too much security so make no mistake
there is no greater deterrent to Bad
actors than having armed security I have
been saying this for years that is why I
continue to advocate for well-trained
armed professionals retired police
retired military at every single School
in the country along with metal
detectors and controlled perimeters
around every school you know we protect
many of our banks businesses politicians
we should do the very same for our kids
now unfortunately the current White
House they're not interested in any
solutions in fact yesterday during a
planned statement about this tragedy in
Nashville Joe Biden who is more
interested in telling jokes and and more
interested in ice cream take a look
my name is Joe Biden
I'm Dr Joe Biden's husband
and I ate Jenny's ice cream chocolate
chip
I came down because I heard there was
chocolate chip ice cream
by the way I have a whole refrigerator
full upstairs you think I'm kidding I'm
not got Ben how are you pal
one of the best guys in the United
States Congress Ben carton
folks uh
welcome to the White House
it's so nice to have you all here
and who are those good looking kids back
there
[Music]
do your kids all four of them well Stand
Up Guys
now Biden's White House Press Secretary
went on to then blame republicans in
Congress for the evil actions committed
by Nashville's shooter take a look at
this
here's the thing what we will say what I
will say to republicans in Congress is
what are you going to say to these
parents what are you going to say to
these family members
now of course the dishonest media mob
they also rushed to politicize this
shooting now in a headline Reuters they
refer to the shooter as a quote former
Christian School student the New York
Times all but apologized for quote
misgendering the killer USA Today
bashing local officials for
misidentifying the gender of the shooter
Newsweek heavily implying that Tennessee
Republicans went to blame because they
banned doctors from performing so-called
gender affirming surgery on children and
banned children from attending drag
shows now somehow the mob the media
politicians they always seem to get in
the way to get even more depraved they
find new ways to go lower and sink lower
tonight our Focus though is with the
people of Nashville they are mourning
they lost six innocent Souls hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis says you will not get it
anywhere else